[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va faire le bilan des 16
ans qu'angela merkel a passées à la tête
de l'allemagne 16 ans pendant lesquels
elle a été la femme la plus puissante
d'europe mais comment c'était le servie
de sa puissance sur le plan national et
sur le plan international pour en
battant pour en débattre pardon nous
avons invité franck dedieu directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du magazine
marianne c'est vous qui avez coordonné
le dernier spécial allemagne paru en
avril dernier le bilan que vous pouvez
feriez de d'angela merkel là en deux
mots et bien écoutez notre essayiste
coralie de l'homme aujourd'hui décédé
avait eu cette expression de ce qu'elle
avait fait le bilan des 15 années
c'était l'année dernière de un gala
merkel avait dit c'est la plus mauvaise
chancelière de l'allemagne depuis
l'après-guerre et je crois que pour des
raisons qui touche à l'économie à la
diplomatie et aux commerces elle a
malheureusement eu raison alors la plus
mauvaise aux yeux des français mais
aussi pour les allemands j'avais envie
de vous dire aux yeux des allemands et
en particulier de la classe moyenne
allemande on y reviendra aux yeux des
français parce que elle elle a appauvri
par sa politique mercantiliste
l'industrie française et puis même aux
yeux du projet européen puisque tout où
finalement tout avancé fédéral a été
a été mise à mal et lorsque
effectivement l'allemagne a changé de
braquet ça a été sous le dire est acculé
jean quatremer vous êtes en direct de
bruxelles où vous êtes le correspondant
du quotidien libération depuis trente
ans me semble-t-il vous tenez également
le blog les coulisses de bruxelles alors
votre bilan à vous donc hélas merkel oh
on risque d'être assez d'accord a
finalement parce que moi je suis très
critique du bilan langue-là merkel
elle a attendu 16 ans enfin presque 15
ans pour comprendre enfin que la terrre
européen est d'intérêt national allemand
n'était pas contradictoire bien au
contraire ce qui était bon pour l'union
européenne était aussi bon pour
l'allemagne et elle s'en est méfié
extrêmement longtemps pour un galet
merkel a surtout été sur seulles hier je
dirais sourit un vrai sens du mot c'est
à dire des gens d'affairé allemand
pendant très longtemps
des mêmes mais aussi à la fin elle a
toujours basculé du côté aux
petits bugs mis en cause et
saluait
alors après il questionné sur sa
longévité parce qu'on n'a pas arrêté de
parler de sa longévité en france 16 ans
il faut dire que rester au pouvoir 16
ans pour les français c'est totalement
incompatible avec la république
le dernier qui est parvenu chez nous
c'est louis napoléon bonaparte il a
fallu qu'il fasse un coup d'état et qui
s'appelle napoléon iii parce que sinon
16 ans personne n'y parvient françois
mitterrand est arrivé à 4 14 ans et
encore avec deux collègues cohabitation
donc c'est vraiment spécial aux
allemands parce que helmut kohl était
déjà resté seize ans avant ghellab
aircal konrad adenauer est resté 14 ans
me semble-t-il
donc ils sont plus coutumier du fait que
nous alors comment quand vous expliquer
c'est quoi les différences pourquoi les
allemands ont bon on sait que c'est pas
des gens comme nous mais à ce point là
ça ne cesse de m'étonner vous avez
explications jean quatremer non c'était
effectivement un mystère vous avez
l'exemple commencer par là alors c'est
vrai que la continuité du temps des de
l'ariège et était plutôt la marque de
règne du fait qu'on la france s'est fait
grâce à des rois qui ont oublié
longtemps blessé pour le temps
démocratie on est maintenant enfin nul
ne sait pas ce que c'est quand même la
seconde chancelière du 21e siècle et qui
reste seize ans au pouvoir c'est vrai
que c'est pour comme en super fientes
alors attention ses 16 ans à la demande
c'est donc davantage dirait la 3è de la
quatrième république que la vème
république
parce que c'est pas
emmanuel macron doté d'une majorité
solide
macron sais je dirais un droit absolu
élu pour cinq ans sans aucun
contre-pouvoir fonctionnel en dirais
même que c'est pas ça elle a gouverné
avec les libéraux dont fait partie la cd
ou à gouverner avec le spd
alternativement c'est une chance vient
d'un compromis et en allemagne la
chancelière s'est plus ils primus inter
pares est ce que un chef de gouvernement
je dirais que lé moins autoritaire par
exemple que le président du conseil
italien elle doit tenir compte aussi
dans la façon de gouverner dans
l'agression même ne compte absolument
parce qu'elle n'a pas les compétences
pour des länder il vaut négocié avec les
patrons extrêmement puissante différents
londres par exemple donner un exemple la
politique de santé publique n'est pas
unique centralisé ses politiques qui
dépend des différents landes d'où la
difficulté qu'elle a eu un manager je
dirais la crise telle peur on le devient
une explication vous l'avez vous avez
évoqué le coup d'état non elle l a fait
tout le contraire d'un coup d'état
et on comprend beaucoup d'états ça veut
dire des coalitions elle a vécu
longtemps sous le régime des coalitions
effectivement en france on n'a pas ce
système là mais quand on avait des
collections sous la quatrième république
les gouvernements durer 15 jours oui
alors là pour le coup c'est plus un
sujet politique de constitutionnel c'est
plus un sujet de mentalité politique où
les roulés boulés coalition s'agrègent
et se désagrège lin ou en allemagne
quand on parle de demain de constitution
d'un gouvernement à noël ça veut dire
qu'un gros ils vont prendre leur temps
en france une coalition où les alliances
parlementaires ça dure quelques minutes
bon là si on parle de noël ça veut quand
même dire qu'ils vont prendre leur temps
ils vont élaborer un projet commun s'il
ya coalition bien entendu et avec qui on
en reparlera donc il ya un premier sujet
quelques cette longévité s'explique par
le régime de coalition et puis d'autre
part effectivement jean quatremer disait
c'est une femme de compromis oui et non
c'est à dire que effectivement vous avez
un cadre institutionnel qui conduit au
compromis mais qui finalement conduit
aussi à une forme de d'indifférenciation
gouvernementale c'est à dire que que ça
soit la gauche on y reviendra le spd l'a
cédée ou vous avez un cadre
constitutionnel et en particulier ce
qu'on appelle l'ordo libéralisme c'est à
dire un cadre constitutionnel qui
définit votre déficit public qui définit
le cadre aussi économique dans lequel
vous agissez qui vous amène finalement à
passer de coalition qui sont par une
sorte de deux forces centripètes vous
conduit vers une politique assez
centriste donc effectivement vous êtes
au pouvoir 16 ans mais quand vous avez
un sigmar gabriel spd ou
un de vos collègues de la cedeao mise
des finances ça change pas grand chose
parce que vous êtes contraint
constitutionnellement et donc cela
favorise finalement à partir du moment
où c'est une pas une peu un pays qui je
dirais a voulu
historiquement
amoindrir les passions politiques et
donc vous êtes forcément dans une
logique de compromis et de longévité de
l'exécutif alors on dit que l'allemagne
n'a jamais été aussi riche
qu'aujourd'hui après seize années dans
gala merkel au pouvoir est ce que pour
autant son bilan intérieur et sans tache
jean quatremer
correspondant à bruxelles
je vais avancer
je vous dire que l'on gala merkel n'a
procédé à aucune grande réforme depuis
qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir toutes les
réformes avait été faite par son
prédécesseur social démocrate gerhard
schröder et des réformes
particulièrement violente des fameuses
doit aspire qui on va sauver le marché
du travail et relancer une croissance
d'un pays que l'on disait être le malade
de l'ordre depuis les années qui réunit
des années 90 et depuis que les dérives
au pouvoir n a fait vraiment que
capitaliser sur ses réformes là elle n'a
fait aucune grande réforme qui est l
espacement attaché au que de prendre
exemple intérieur dokalam à moderniser
le vit dans le pays aurait besoin d'être
modernisée il a fallu attendre la faire
par exemple exemple la sphère du diesel
gay pour qu'enfin il avait un livre que
il va falloir travailler va falloir
changer le modèle il est le point
économique de l'allemagne qui fondée en
grande partie sur l'exploitation des
voitures le point adapter au xxième
siècle la chancelière angela merkel n'a
pas un bon bilan mais qu'il dut à
schoder pour rejoindre ce qu'il disait
d'ailleurs ces lieux qui on voit bien
des réformes de droite les réformes les
plus durs n'ont pas été faites par la
droite est loin des fêtes par la gauche
en allemagne est ça qui est intéressant
c'est vrai qu'un logiciel allemand qui
est un logiciel constitutionnel mais
encore une fois pourquoi est-ce que
c'est comme ça il faut faire un petit
peu d'histoire je remplis un petit pas
en arrière on ne l'est pas ce sont des
alliés après la seconde guerre mondiale
qui ont construit le système
institutionnel allemand mais aussi le
système économique allemand on a tout
fait dans la constitution qui a été
écrit par les américains il faut combien
comprendre que ça fait c'est pas du tout
une invention allemande la constitution
allemande défi pour les ânes est pas
américain pour éviter que un seul homme
ou une seule femme et l'ensemble des
pouvoirs et puissent
de nouveau si vous voulez
renouer avec le nazi salue les coupes et
les dents et les zombies mais les ombres
du pouvoir central allemand et en
matière économique c'est exactement la
même chose c'est éviter que l'allemagne
en matière économique même une autre
politique que celle qu'elle a menées
depuis 1949
de l'indépendance d'après après guerre
une fois que les avis ont évacué le
mènent donc à l'époque les américains
savaient gagner une guerre il écrivait
une constitution et ça marchait après
sais pas
c'est très intéressant votre marque
parce que effectivement il ya deux cas
ça a marché c'est l'allemagne et le
japon mais c'est parce que c'est du
délit où il y avait une tradition
démocratique auparavant ils n'ont pas
apporté la démocratie existe et ils ont
rétabli c'est peut-être pour ça que ça
fonctionne et ça n'est pas le cas j'ai
tellement de vieillissement miracle
j'ai été très étonné que dans les
journaux français là depuis qu'on on
célèbre un gala merkel ont dit
systématiquement quelle a été la plus
jeune au poste de chancelier à 51 ans il
oublie quand même adolf hitler qui était
à 46 ans normalement on n'oublie pas
baden fittler on fonce mais la wii bon
effectivement je sais pas si on a aussi
dit on a beaucoup dit que c'était la
femme la plus puissante du monde moi je
suis assez d'europe c'est certain oui de
refuser d'europe bruits mais pas bien
des classements américains qui l'ont
plusieurs fois classé parmi les femmes
le plus affreux là et puis bon elle a
commencé très jeune aussi à l'incarner
l'allemande de l'est et puis quelque
part aussi 7
une forme d'émancipation des femmes aux
seins allemagne de l'est et puis dans
l'allemagne dans son entièreté moi je
suis assez faux jeu il faut rappeler en
ce qui concerne l'allemagne de l'est
elle a été la porte parole du
gouvernement de lothar de maizière donc
le premier gouvernement démocratique
entre la chute du communisme en rda et
la réunification allemande il ya un
gouvernement démocratique c'est là
qu'elle fait ses débuts en politique ce
qui lui donne une certaine légitimité
plus avoir à l'époque les trappes une
légitimité à la fois géographique et
puis une légitimité aussi démocratique
puisqu'elle fait partie elle accompagne
ce mouvement mais moi je suis étonné au
delà de l'âge ou du genre par les
lauriers que la presse
dresse 13 pardon à aa à djeddah merkel
fin tu veux dire il ya très très peu
alors malheureusement vous avez
l'impression que vous avez invité les
deux critiques de la presse française
bon mais si vous voulez je sais pas
quand vous êtes débrouiller mais
effectivement c'est quand même
incroyable je n'ai jamais vu ça au après
une passation de pouvoir une telle une
telle célébration d'un bilan qui en plus
est là peut-être on y reviendra à
participer à désindustrialisé notre pays
pour une raison qui est liée au fait que
nous avons la même monnaie c'est un peu
là peut-être que vous aurez des
questions
est à sur ce sujet et alors justement
sûr mais sur le plus particulièrement
sur sur la situation en allemagne
l'environnement semble être le point
faible de 2 du règne dans gala merkel
ont souvient de sa sortie du nucléaire
qui a pu sembler absurde d'ailleurs
après après fukushima ça chante les
tsunamis en allemagne sont tassés à elle
à fermer les centrales et en gros elle
est retournée aux centrales à charbon
oui alors effectivement vous avez tout à
fait raison c'est une absurdité qui a
été très mal vécu en france et en
particulier par emmanuel bach rond parce
que notamment tourné le dos au nucléaire
ça suppose aussi quelque part tourné le
dos un peu plus davantage à la france
appelez-vous cette phrase d'orson welles
que j'aime bien à propos du couple
franco-allemand unis dans un couple y en
a toujours un qui souffrent et un autre
qui s'ennuient eh bien les français ont
souffert et particuliers emmanuel macron
a souffert de cette de ce revirement sur
le nucléaire là où pour le coup c'est c
on peut reprocher à gérer merkel de ne
pas avoir vu finalement cette transition
du 21e siècle c'est que les allemands
vont comprendre que tourner le dos à
l'écologie s'est aussi tourné le dos à
l'économie parce que effectivement on a
pu dire qu'elle a mis l'économie au
dessus de tout du politique bien sûr
mais à partir de cette le secteur
automobile à allemands notamment après
le désert gates on s'est aperçu qu'il
n'avait pas du tout investi sur la
transition pour passer du moteur
thermique au moteur électrique alors
effectivement vous avez quand même des
grands groupes qui commence ce qu'ils
ont qui font des progrès et qui
rattrapent leurs progrès technologiques
sur le plan thermique mais vous
apercevez que ce qui a fait la force
aussi l'allemagne cessons ce sont des
petites villes avec des fournisseurs des
grands groupes homebrews vague n bmw qui
sont pour le coup eux à la différence du
donneur d'ordre qui est géant etc à la
capacité quand même à accélérer pour
regagner à technologiquement le retard
perdu sur le sur le nucléaire pardon sur
le sur l'électrique et sur la batterie
vous avez une kyrielle de petites villes
qui ne vivent que par des fournisseurs
qui eux pour le coup en énormément de
retard technologique et l'a finalement
c'est aussi tu dirais un point faible
d'indiana recueil c'est que il y a eu un
pari à faire sur l'écologie qui se mêle
à l'économie et un particulier un
particulier dans le secteur de
l'automobile jean quatremer
sur le nucléaire c'est françois hollande
qui a souffert et panels macro parce que
c'était antérieur
c'est lui qui avait vraiment pris par
surprise personne attendait un processus
commercial dans le processus commercial
c'est quand même macron cana mesure
récupérer le la perte en volume alors
donc oui c'est typique de la façon
d'ailleurs donc ouvert angela merkel
c'est à dire des décisions unilatérales
dans des domaines qui impacte
directement la france le nucléaire est
un exemple on pourrait aussi citer la
crise migratoire en 2015 où elle a
décidé d'accueillir à c'est très bien
mais je la félicite plus d'un million de
réfugiés mais sans consulter personne
autour d'elle se détend encore une fois
c'est vrai que c'était mort
très tendues entre la france et
l'allemagne mais les français ont un
avenir la même tendance en matière de
politique étrangère dire que
généralement on commence à bombarder un
pays avant d'avertir les allemands
décident de reprendre nos essais
nucléaires à 1995 on oublie en appelant
la chancellerie dix minutes avant dirais
que ses mauvaises manières et la
consubstantielle à cette europe
confédérale il a chuté mais quand je
parlais de retardant enfin je parlais du
nucléaire mais de l'environnement en
général et plus du point de vue des
allemands l'occurrence et pas seulement
parce que nous ça nous ferait pas ce que
ça nous énerverait sur le numérique
aussi je crois que l'allemagne est à peu
près au niveau de l'albanie
hélas et les anneaux qui on souffre
c'est pas les français un jean quatremer
oui vous avez tout à fait raison et il
ya la question aussi du
sous-investissement
allemand dans les infrastructures là
c'est une question et on passe notre
temps en france et moi-même je dois dire
que je j'ai fait pas si longtemps ans
c'est la même chose à dire que je
donnais un vecteur l'allemagne en
exemple en matière de gestion des
comptes publics le problème c'est que
l'exemple allemand n'est pas forcément
le bon exemple à suivre en entrant en
rencontres aujourd'hui l'investissement
dans le numérique vous avez raison de le
citer et une catastrophe je veux dire
que le rock le débit ou la cage et la
salle j'ai par exemple du débit internet
et d'une catastrophe sans nom je parle
pas des infrastructures routières ou
plus de 10% aux autoroutes allemands
s'en rappelle praticable dès conquis ces
fonds nous en avons aussi des beaucoup
moins que les allemands l'etrat toujours
en retard contrairement à ce qu'on croit
la capacité aussi de faire les gros
travaux publics comme on l'a vu avec la
saga interminable de l'aéroport de
berlin ila il ya un vrai problème de
rapport à la dénonce à la dépense
publique en elle-même vous rappelle
qu'ils ont mis un frein après la crise
de la zone euro un frein à l'endettement
est un frein ou déficits publics mais il
est question de le remettre en cause
parce que sk vient montrer la pandémie
de chorales un virus pour le coup c'est
qu'il était vraiment nécessaire
aujourd'hui d'investir massivement de
l'argent public pour préparer l'économie
du futur
c'est pas hasard servi comme la chine en
l'espace de trente ans à la perle rare
d'un devis rita siècle est aujourd'hui
en train de manger la laine sur le dos
des américains ils ont investi le cdta
qu'a pris en main l'économie et qui a
investi massivement en france ou en
europe on a au fond la mettra gauchy
c'est l'état qui doit intervenir pour
soutenir son économique les américains
ou une autre tradition on consomme pas
comparable aux américains hélas la
pandémie a montré que en investissant
massivement on était capable de relancer
la croissance dans la question
maintenant c'est tout l'enjeu des
rapports franco allemand pour les années
à venir c est ce que ces investissements
sont durs a été fait dans des secteurs
qui vont créer de la croissance parce
que si une partie du pont d'en vestit du
clan investissements européens à trouver
une femme c'est 150 milliards qu'on a
emprunté en commun et qui seront
remboursés en conscients de la richesse
de chacun quelque chose de tout à fait
nouveau sam union européenne ont jugé
finalement un os il ya encore 50 si cet
argent est bien dépensé et relance la
croissance
ça pourrait réhabiliter la dépense
publique l'endettement auprès légèrement
donc ses nageoires surveiller ce qui se
passe dans les deux trois prochaines
années
de dieu je crains que ça ça ferait très
difficile de réhabiliter l'un des deux
ment aux yeux des allemands premièrement
parce que c'est malgré tout une
population vieillissante et la crainte
fondée ou pas de retour à l'inflation
est quelque chose qui angoissent
beaucoup les allemands qui se disent
finalement je vais avoir une perte de
mon pouvoir d'achat les la politique de
la bce banque centrale européenne pour
la réalisation de laquelle nous avons
tordu le bras enfin nous les pays du sud
à halle allemagne
produit des taux zéro c'est à dire que
vous avez de l'épargné qui n'est plus
rémunéré et donc je crains que ça va
être très difficile de remettre en cause
l'idée du frein à l'endettement et enfin
et j'en connais bien les mieux que moi
les questions de droit mais ça suppose
une révision de la constitution
c'est-à-dire une majorité qualifiée à
l'assemblée alors ils auront du mal à se
mettre d'accord pour former une
coalition c'est à dire pour avoir 50,1
pour cent des sièges mais alors pour
remettre en cause la constitution sur un
sujet qui est aussi je veux dire est
consubstantielle à allah l'esprit
allemand de l'après-guerre ça va être
extrêmement difficile et c'est en ce
sens que les les jours qui s'annoncent
pour la coalition je dirais spd enfin
encore que ses avoirs et biens seront
très difficiles entre l'allemagne qui va
caler moyens grâce à à l'euro pour faire
simple qu'est les moyens industriels de
de tenir ses engagements en terme
d'endettement à peu près à peu près
effectivement c'est sous investis mais
ça fait des années qu'ils sont investis
et puis les pays du sud qui évidemment
redécouvre les vertus de l'endettement à
taux zéro donc effectivement à taux zéro
quand vous avez vous avez c'est très
simple même pas besoin d'être embarqué
d'affaires pour comprendre vous arrivez
à avoir un financement à 0% si vous
n'investissez dans des secteurs verts
qui ont je dirais une capacité d'avoir
des économies en termes d'énergie vous
avez 3 4 % de rendement un état qui gère
à très très très long terme quitte à
avoir des retours au bout de vingt ou
trente ans la rénovation thermique c'est
quelque chose qui rapporte quand vous
êtes vous lever de l'argent à 0 % ça ça
peut paraître très simple c'est vraiment
un calcul que fait n'importe quel
financiers ce qui lève de l'argent sur
les marchés financiers toute la journée
ils font ça regardez à quel coût je
m'endette et à quel rendement je place
le produit dont l'endettement est bien
même je crois dans l'esprit des
allemandes qui ont quand même pas voter
massivement pour le spd il faut bien
l'avouer tout le monde dit 24 25 % c'est
énorme on ça reste quand même très peu
moi je serai peut-être moins positifs ou
moins optimiste que jean il faut bien
comprendre que non seulement ces
tractations peuvent durer des mois mais
à la fin ce sera peut-être pas le
gagnant d'hier qui sera chancelier ça
peut être le vaincus d'hier qui arrive à
faire une coalition alors que le
vainqueur n'y voit rien pas dépendra de
la couleur voilà c'est quelque part vous
avez la cd ou plus
plus
le fdp les libéraux et plus les verts
vous avez la possibilité d'avoir et puis
en avoir une à quatre parties aussi là
et il est arrivé vous dit noël mais il
est arrivé que ça ne compte qu ils n'y
parviennent qu'en mars oui mais vous
remarquerez qu un peu comme en belgique
c'est à dire que y'a une telle haine
différenciation politique il ya une
telle
mentalité au sein de l'union européenne
de pauli 2-2 pilotage automatique de
l'économie en particulier quand vous
avez un cadre constitutionnel qui vous
entourent que finalement ça change pas
grand chose et c'est ça qui à mon avis
pose la question de la souveraineté du
peuple qui se dit mais au fond on a des
alternances des coalitions et les choses
ne changent pas ce que disait jean il
disait je rôde finalement elle n'a pas
fait de réformes oui elle n'a pas elle
n'a rien n'a pas théorisé la réforme
mais en revanche elle la mise en place
avec un entêtement granitique supérieur
à celui de son prédécesseur
réaction de jean quatremer très rapide
dans une minute 40 ont fait une pause
actuellement
ils sont quelques uns le cadre
constitutionnel
s'est passé quand même depuis deux ans
quelque chose dès 9 ans qui a été amendé
mis l'équipe consulaire européens en
l'occurrence le pacte de stabilité les
règles de concurrence et c'est tout fait
exploser véritablement tout fait
exploser tout ce qui était un temps j il
ya deux ans désormais et remise tamic
dire que entendre pour cela von der
leyen qui est la présidente allemande de
la cd ou président de la commission
européenne qui vous explique qu'il ne
faut surtout pas à renouer avec les
règles de stabilité budgétaire
c'est-à-dire avec le pacte de stabilité
trop vite parce que ce qui a entraîné
justement la longue des primes de la
croissance post crise de la zone euro
parce qu'on est trop c'est trop la
cellule ont trop rapidement et donc il
faut revoir même les règles du pacte de
stabilité budgétaire
que leur matière d'aidés d'état il faut
se laisser suspendu l'ensemble des reds
européenne s'est complètement facilement
il ya deux ans elle n'est juste pas
possible ici véritablement je crois que
le les vieux logiciels ont explosé en
plein vol
je viens c'est clair parce que je
m'attendais pas à ce que ça fonctionne
franchement je m'attendais pas à ce que
l'aîné massive
des budgets étatiques période de manière
l'économie à flot et mieux la prononcer
de façon pressel et contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser il ya deux ans
donc je reconnais mais loupe à la maxime
est coupable ce qui paie mais parce que
depuis trente ans on vivait
effectivement dans des croyances
injustifiée et ça ça peut aussi
atteindre les allemands vous jamais
désespérer de l'allemagne et de sa
capacité à s'adapter
on fait une pause et or pro ce débat
[Musique]
la france et d'autres pays du globe
doivent faire face à une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre comment expliquer ce phénomène
depuis tout temps vous avez eu un taux
de chômage important et puis en revanche
des demandes des entreprises pour
engager des gens et qui ne se
rencontraient pas parce que formation
insuffisante parce que l'inadéquation
entre les gens qui étaient sur le marché
du travail est ce que cherchait les
entreprises et à chaque reprise
économique on bute sur des normes
pénurie de main d'oeuvre si on répond
pas tout de suite avec la concurrence il
peut y avoir des effondrements de
certains pans de notre activité
c'est un phénomène sur lequel il faut
travailler sur le temps long
malheureusement le connaissez tous le
temps politique il n'est pas en temps
longs il les entend élections par
élections
[Musique]
cette réforme du franc cfa ne semble pas
faire l'unanimité sur le continent
l'afrique doit s'unir pour créer sa
propre monnaie indépendant c'est la
politique qui va être au coeur du
processus de création monétaire parce
que la monnaie est un fait social total
ce n'est pas qu'on fait économique cette
monnaie cedeao ne pourrait être un
succès que signent un véritable
engagement des états en termes de
solidarité est ce que la réforme du
franc cfa va permettre de couper ce
cordon ombilical avec la france il y a
des gens qui sont dans la défense d'un
système qui a vécu c'est sur le système
de la françafrique avec le français
phare qui me semble être le dernier
avatar de la colonisation française en
arc
[Musique]
et
on reprend ce débat sur le bilan non
biella merkel avec franck dedieu qui est
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
magazine marianne et jean quatremer le
correspondant à bruxelles du quotidien
libération qui se trouve d'ailleurs en
direct avec nous deux bruxelles j'aurais
juste qu'on s'arrête sur le fait qu'
angela merkel a grandi en allemagne de
l'est ce qu'on sait pas forcément en
france c'est que son père qui était
pasteur a emmené sa famille en allemagne
de l'est
ils font partie des très très rare
pendant la guerre froide qui sont passés
à l'est sans y être obligé je veux dire
c'est pas comme burgess et bag line qui
était qu'ils étaient obligés parce qu'il
était convaincu d'espionnage ll je sais
pas il doit y avoir que que lee harvey
oswald avant la famille merkel qui est
passé à l'est est encore lhuillier pas
resté les revenus eux ils sont restés et
elle est restée jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à
la chute du mur 35 ans dans une
dictature communiste comme celle de la
rda ça laisse des traces j'imagine que
vous les voyez où vous jean quatremer
chez angela merkel m as on les voit dans
sont gérés dans son attachement très
mesurés sont communautaires c'était une
véritable rupture avec une coque et son
mentor
après l'unification de l'allemagne et là
vraiment on aime quelqu'un qui n'est
qu'il ne partageait pas notre notre
vision commune de l'histoire et cpv
ricanements en frappant parce que
pour helmut kohl l'europe c'était
quelque chose qu'il avait au coeur qu'il
avait dans le temps qu'il avait nos
lectrices c'était la façon dont c'était
la meilleure façon d'éviter à nouveau
une conflagration europe et d une guerre
franco allemand la troisième depuis 10
il ya eu trois verres la france et
l'allemagne 70 cents 14-18 et 39-45 et
qui ont laissé le continent à genoux
donc il l'avait connu et il avait connu
aussi la reconstruction allégorie de la
reconstruction d'après-guerre et avec
tout travail de culpabilité sur la
culpabilité alors des erreurs aborde la
dernière malement et c'est alors que à
l'est elle l'a pas du tout connu ce
moment là il faut bien voir ce temps je
peux j'en connais encore là je suis
vraiment à la limite de mes compétences
mais qu'à l'est il est considéré ne se
considérait pas comme les héritiers du
nazisme mais comme les héritiers de la
résistance au nazisme que qui en 1945 ce
qui est quand même des restes étaient
quasiment personne parce qu'on voit là
il clair ayant fait un travail de
liquidation extrêmement efficace donc
pour r c'était pas son histoire et éco
telle est arrivé on a vu un véritable
changement dans l'attitude allemande à
l'égard de l'europe et on va raconter un
des scènes absolument surréaliste à la
chancellerie où elle était quand même
entouré de quelques conseillers
de cité au début de la crise de la zone
euro à la crise financière de nutte
scène les débuts de la crise de la zone
euro devaient lui vous c'était comment
empêcher les français de faire avancer
des idées parmi les capitales
européennes et donc témoin a raconté
c'est un événement la naissance de la
cité une réunion de grands états-majors
allemand pour contenir l'avancée des
troupes napoléoniennes
en prusse c'est pour vous montrer le
changement d'état d'esprit totale par
rapport à la période et nous prouve mais
je précise aussi que ça déconne c'est
quand même ce choix d'heure qui n'avait
pas connu la seconde guerre mondiale les
docks été moins attachés que helmut kohl
pas la construction communautaire six
derniers points excusez moi que
angela merkel a été la première
chancelière berlinoise c'est quelque
chose de fondamental elle n'a jamais ni
bonne c'est à dire peut être cette ville
sympathie comme cologne c'est la règle
est prêt de la france ces espèces on est
très proche des maisons qu'ils avaient
envahi s'est pas éloigné tellement de
l'alsace donc franchement on se sent
presque chez nous à berlin c'est très
moi c'est au nez on a le regard tourné
vers l'est on est presque à la frontière
polonaise c'est une autre vision et on
voit paris d'extrêmement donc c'est une
autre vision du bourg rien mais ça n'a
pas été facile pour la chansonnière de
faire un chemin
bonne je rappelle pour les plus jeunes
qui nous regardent c'était la capitale
de la république fédérale allemande
l'allemagne de l'ouest 1 from de dieu
oui c'était sous les ailes a
effectivement elle avait porté un regard
j'irai très critique sur l'avancée l'
influence française au sein de l'union
européenne on l'a vu comment elle a
torpillé le projet d'union de la
méditerranée
c'est typique de cela mais ce qu'elle a
fait je pense qu'elle l'a un peu
conjugué à la sauce économique c'est à
dire que effectivement il s'agissait pas
de retenir des troupes ou quoi que ce
soit il s'agissait de faire le
mercantilisme du mercantilisme c'est à
dire de se tenir au fond dans l'intérêt
national de l'allemagne est-ce que je
dois être davantage européenne ou alors
me tourner vers d'autres contrées en
période de d'émergence économique et là
effectivement elle s'est aperçue au bout
d'un moment je me souviens très bien de
cette époque que les allemands
finissaient par dire mais au fond nous
n'avons plus besoin de l'union
européenne nous faisons des excédents
commerciaux avec la chine et quelque
part l'union européenne s'est davantage
de virer un frein à la fois ces pays ces
fameux pigs quand on a comme moquer ou
cpi club med qui nous coûtait de
l'argent et au fond c'est en se tournant
vers l'est et vers la chine que eh bien
il y avait des promesses de débouchés
pour pour l'allemagne pour la puissance
économique allemande bon il se trouve
que là où on peut faire un bilan très
critique d'angela merkel je lui ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'elle n'avait pas
compris ce passage de dirait du
thermique à l'électrique donc quelque
part de l'économie à l'écologie mais là
pas aussi compris que les chinois
avaient mené un peu comme elle
d'ailleurs une politique quelque part
d'auto suffisance c'est à dire quand
vous voyez aujourd'hui le plan qui a été
décidée le plan quinquennal par xi
jingping vous apercevez qu'il ya
véritablement une volonté de créer une
demande intérieure une volonté de
produire eux mêmes en chine et donc
effectivement angela merkel s'est
retrouvé à la vue la fin de sa serre que
ce changement de modèle
chinois
ironie suprême de l'histoire qui renouer
avec une forme de communisme
nationaliste un peu à la halle à
khrouchtchev quelque part avec ce désir
d'autosuffisance 1 eh bien allez faire
comme première victime l'allemagne
lorsqu'elle s'est aperçue et bien à ce
moment là elle a changé d'optique sur
l'union européenne tout simplement parce
que l'intérêt national de l'allemagne
n'était à ce moment là plus de se
tourner vers la chine mais de tout
simplement de se retourner vers vers
vers ses partenaires européens en qui
elle pouvait avoir davantage confiance
alors justin long sur le plan européen
puisque je le dis a été pendant 16 ans
la femme la plus puissante d'europe
angela merkel au moment de la crise des
'subprimes' et de la crise ensuite de
l'euro qui lui fait suite qui on est
pour ainsi dire les conséquences est-ce
qu'elle a été bonne
on était totalement catastrophique elle
n'a rien compris à ce qui se passait
musée
les allemands globalement
ça va extrêmement vite comprennent pas
grand chose à l'économie et encore on la
finance internationale comme si tous les
meilleurs économistes allemands avaient
fichu le camp après 1945 pour se
réfugier aux états unis c'est assez
brutal ce que je dis la vérité en mai en
2007 au moment où la crise des subprimes
explose aux états unis elle ne veut pas
voir que ça va avoir des conséquences
pour l'ensemble de l'union européenne
pas seulement pour les pays les plus
faibles mais y compris pour l'allemagne
et là ça apparaît au grand jour pendant
un an ça tient tant bien que mal grâce à
l'action de la banque centrale
européenne je rappelle à des mois d'août
2007 le si décrié à gauche jean claude
trichet comprendre en train de se passer
lui et puis ouvre grand les robinet à
liquidités qui évite d'envoyer du
système bancaire
européen mais c'est à partir du 15
septembre 2008 ont vraiment vous
rappelez de la faillite de la banque
d'affaires lehman brothers que là on
voit toute l'incompétence de la
chancelière
sarkozy nicolas sarkozy comprend ce qui
va se passer il convoque à paris une
réunion des camions au point de vue du
g7 à l'époque cet accord logique puisque
là aussi il y assister
pour essayer de prendre des mesures pour
éviter que le système bancaire européen
ne s'effondre et la réunion se passe
extrêmement mal parce que la chance le
bière considère que ça va être un
problème pour les banques du sud les
fameux pigs mon franck a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est évidemment là le portugal
l'irlande
l'italie le portugal et longuement la
france n'est pas la seule crise au liban
à allende qui m ont résisté et quand
elle rentre chez elle le soir
d'halloween et des horreurs nicolas
sarkozy à ses conseillers ce soir là oui
bon gros nous à vis des textos à chacun
sa mère et de rentrer chez elles de soi
et l'est en arrivant à berlin l'a fait
la qualité de la principale banque
hypothécaire allemande qui s'appelait
hypo real estate qui fait faillite et à
ce moment là le téléphone à l'image
apaisant ouais alors finalement à la
portée d'un plan européen c'est une
poudre mauvaise idée parce que ça
pouvait s'en rend compte que tout seul
elle n'a pas y arriver donc elle a
besoin pour le coup que tous les pays
européens vous vous même maman leurs
vannes budgétaires pour qui des normands
la samo qu'elle ne comprend de nenê n'a
pas voulu voir ensuite les débuts de la
crise économique je vous rappelle que
nicolas sarkozy allait proposer un grand
plan européen
les économies elle l'a refusée ça sera
une série de plans nationaux non
coordonnées nicolas sarkozy va proposer
une ckcv lille est l'équivalent d'une
communauté économique du charbon et
d'acier dans le domaine de l'industrie
automobile et notamment des batteries
électriques était super bien rue
nicolas sarkozy le président de droite
pas les cinq enseignants dans notre
histoire mais n'ont pas suivi les débuts
en h hne on en est là aujourd'hui dix
ans plus tard et avec regret a refusé
donc ça a été une série
d'incompréhensions
d'incapacité de la prévoir qu'ils nous
ont entraînés collectivement dans la
crise et là après ça ça ça va
some more ou maman de la crise grecque
la crise de la zone euro
alors la crise de la zone euro on peut
enchaîner
en fait effectivement il ya eu une
erreur d'appréciation de la part d'un
gala merkel mais plus tard après les
premiers effets l'hymne post lehman
brothers il ya quand même eu un tour de
vis c'est à dire c'est le pacte de
stabilité c'est les six pack les to pacs
ou là elle a gain de cause c'est à dire
que les français finissent par
s'incliner devant cette cette politique
osterrieth ère où on se dit qu'il va
falloir réduire des taux d'endettement
fin c'était à l'époque c'était dingue
les taux d'endettement il parce qu'au
départ on injecte de l'argent dans les
cours d'eau on injecte mais très vite on
arrête c'est à dire qu'après ya eu une
phase où on se dit bon maintenant on
arrête parce que les taux sont élevés
que c'est pas conforme au règlement
européen et donc effectivement là on
rentre dans une logique de 2,2
d'austérité et pour le coup les élites
françaises accepte cela elle acceptera
en disant c'est l'austérité ou la mort
rappelez-vous françois fillon qui dit je
suis à la tête d'un pays en faillite
donc toute cette logique là toute cette
logique là qui est d'inspiration
osterrieth air ordolibérale angela
merkel réussi à l'imposer aux autres
elles réussi à l'imposer aurait réussi à
l'imposer de façon diplomatique avec les
français et puis de façon très très dur
il faut rappeler quand même quelle est
l'attitude du ministre des finances
je trouve que là sur la grèce par
exemple est-ce qu'elle a sauvé est ce
que la grèce est sauvée
non non la grèce n'est pas sauvée parce
qu'à l'époque que le but de ce tag
s'opposent angela merkel sur le sort de
la grèce non l'a finalement cmd la barre
quelques raccords a le dernier mot me
semble-t-il est ce qu elle a sauvé la
grèce ou pas pas du tout elle a pas du
tout sauver la grèce elle a appauvri
c'est à dire qu'elle avait en échange de
ces prêts de cette injection d'argent
elle voulait des réformes structurelles
qui ont conduit 2 degrés en degrés à
faire en sorte que les les grecs vent de
leurs actifs et certains
industriels allemands en acheter des
actifs des désastres feu grecque et puis
résultat vous avez une sorte de
contraction de l'économie qui fait que
même si vous devez rembourser que vous
avez deux façons très comptable très
mode et l'excellent des tokido
d'endettement qui finissent par baisser
encore que c'est très discutable parce
que lorsque vous baissez votre richesse
nationale et qui baissent plus que votre
endettement vous avez un ratio c'est à
dire un taux qui le du taux
d'endettement qui fini par augmenter
c'est ce qui s'est passé en grèce alors
c'est un peu moins vrai aujourd'hui mais
c'était on a mis en fait la grèce dans
une situation
d'appauvrissement de rétrécissement
économique alors ce que pourrait dire
gens c'est à dire oui mais si on avance
dans une logique de redistribution
budgétaire et sociale de mise en commun
des budgets à ce moment là c'est vrai
que il ya une région entre guillemets
états-nations une région de l'union
européenne qui finalement est contrainte
de vivre avec une monnaie très forte
mais qui peut quand même à tout attirer
des touristes du tourisme et puis d'être
fort d'un deux où trois secteurs et au
fond s'il y a des transferts sociaux et
des transferts budgétaires et bien au
fond ça fonctionne le problème c'est que
l'union européenne ne fonctionne pas
comme ça et je crois qu'elle aura du mal
à fonctionner comme ça comme disait al
de gaulle on ne fait pas une omelette
avec des os dur et les états-nations
cuisse depuis bien longtemps au
bain-marie pour reposer une force très
lui dire et puissante à tout projet
fédéraliste alors jean quatremer angela
merkel et la grèce et puis angela merkel
avec la zone la crise de la zone euro
une photo je sais pas je vais pas entrer
dans ce débat je les crée un énorme
bouquet par la crise grecque puis je
vais dire quand même voudrais dire deux
choses la crise grecque c'est presque y
il faut reconnaître n'aurait jamais dû
rentrer dans la zone euro ce tapis qui
n'était pas avait pourri dans la zone
euro est l'erreur de départ a été
commise par tout le monde les
institutions communautaires mais aussi
les états membres qui ont donné leur
accord elle de limiter et parmi ces
évidemment un certain nombre qui
s'appelle de l'allemagne donc s'il avait
voulu s'y opposer la grèce se serait
jamais entrés dans l'âge allons donc
erreur colitti
la grève chris grey et aurait pu être
évitée avec un seul ou un saut sacrés
crise de l'aviation bref c'est à dire
que brutalement des investisseurs
institutionnels qui possédait la la
crise grecque voilà belga la belgique se
sont mis à la vente en b y en se disant
que rap serait peut-être pas de
solidarité entre les pays européens pour
rembourser une dette qui quand même sens
et mauvais en 2009 masque on nous
rappelait il avait annoncé que en fait
leur déficit réel et est trois fois plus
élevé que le déficit a lancé
il suffisait de dire un mot l'allemagne
sera solidaire de la grèce quoi qu'il
arrive et ça se serait arrêtée dans la
seconde il ya un an auparavant il ya eu
des mouvements sur les marchés hélas ce
moment là c'était une majorité cd ou spd
et le spd avait convaincu la chancelière
demain l'espèce est solidarité et les
premières attaques des marchés c'était
arables au moment de la seconde crise
grecque
de demi-lune femmes des mineurs la
majorité a changé là vous avez la cdo
qui gouverne avec les libéraux du fdp
les libéraux du dp refuse toute toute
union de transferts toute solidarité et
c'est là que commence la triste c'est à
ce moment-là elle mettra cinq ans enfin
à sauver la grèce entre guillemets c'est
à dire à s'opposer à la volonté son
ministre des finances comme sur les
blocs d'expulser la grèce de la zone
euro ce qui est plutôt bien vu parce que
si elle avait exclu c'est la blague la
zone euro il y aurait eu sans doute à
mes frais nominaux mais quand on regarde
le jour d'aujourd'hui après le premier
scandale argent public qu'on a dépensé
l'argent public qu'on a mis en commun
pour relancer en commun à l'ensemble des
économies de la zone euro on se dit mais
on agit tout ça à la grèce pour quelques
des centaines de milliards à l'euro même
pas dire quelques dizaines de milliards
d'euros et pendant cinq ans on a fait
souffrir tout un peu pourquoi
c'est pour me disait que l'argent ne
pousse pas dans les arbres lorsque l'on
30 des ventes en uc que l'argent pousse
dans les arts on en met à dire il n'ya
pas leur faire de marge en hélicoptère
pour relancer les économies d'énergie ne
peut bien seul hic c'est la bce qui a
pris bélier et qui distribue l'argent
mis l'euro 2000 euros ou ménages pour
relancer la croissance c'est là où on en
est aujourd'hui donc toutes nos
croyances en fait les croyances
allemande pour l'essentiel un pas du
tout aux françaises des patineurs qui
ont fait de facto souffrir les grecs
cela étant il faut être sérieux moi je
connais bien la grèce parce qu'on t'en
reste et je peux vous dire que j'avais
besoin de réformes structurelles
extrêmement profonde est que aujourd'hui
quand on entend l'hymne gré se plaindre
le niveau des impôts vous vous amusez
parce que le niveau des impôts en grèce
ça reste à peu près le tiers du niveau
des impôts en france c'est quand même
pas la misère absolue c'est ça le réel
est donc celle obligé le pays à ceux à
se moderniser voilà mais franchement la
responsabilité de l'allemagne dans la
crise grecque puis ensuite dans la crise
aussi portugaises espagnoles avec serrar
est il absolument monstrueuse ya un mois
il faudra qu'il fasse un minimum d'auto
critique sur leur attitude à ce moment
là et c'est pour ça et d'ajouter au
sujet actualité que moi je le crains que
j'avais une participation des libéraux
du fdp au nouveau gouvernement parce que
des libéraux du fdp
ce sont vraiment les casques à pointes
de l'économie en elle même ils veulent
le ministère des finances si j'obtiens
le ministère des finances ils vont
vouloir compromettre le pacte de
stabilité celui qui a été négociée en 96
ils vont vouloir revenir à l'orthodoxie
budgétaire
vous pouvez insérer tous les freins
budgétaires possibles et ils vont
refuser selon l'ansa second fonds de
relance
européen de la défense et c'est bien un
élément commun pérenne et là à mon avis
on va vers lui 4 alors dernière question
la crise de 2015 la crise des réfugiés
personne ne veut n'en veut en europe et
anglais la mère qu'elle dit l'allemagne
en accueillera un million et elle dit
cette phrase qui resté célèbre on va y
arriver est-ce qu'ils y sont arrivés
est ce que l'allemagne aujourd'hui avec
un million de réfugiés en plus et depuis
je crois à peu près de 250 mille par an
est-ce que ça va alors ça fait monter
l'extrême droite enfin de ce côté là
nous aussi on a accueilli quasiment
personne
est ce qu'elle a réussi vous avez raison
ça fait quand même monter l'extrême
droite est redescendu d'huile d'accord
mais enfin c'est quand même pas rien
deuxièmement
ça a donné aussi un argument pour dire
au fond c'était à même la meilleure
façon de faire de faire encore une
pression sur les salaires et donc
quelque part or je pense qu'il ya une
part d'humanité évidemment oui je pense
que c'est une fille de pasteur elle
pense aussi à son salut parce que on
était quand même sauvé lé jusque là elle
est vite on est elle estime qu'elle
édite une catastrophe humanitaire voilà
donc l est les eps davis là comme je
disais elle pense à son salut je dirai
au regard de l'histoire puisque on
arrive presque en fin de course mais il
faut bien avouer que ça aussi contribué
à faire baisser le coût salarial
notamment dans le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire et puis deuxièmement
ça aussi ça a été un coup supplémentaire
pour dire au fond la compétitivité
allemande
lll on gagne quelques points en
compétitivité puisque on arrive malgré
l'instauration d'un smic qui est quand
même assez bas on arrive tout de même à
contenir les salaires et puis on
continue à exporter puisqu'on n'arrive
pas je dirais maintenir des coûts qui
sont relativement stables jean quatremer
elle a été la seule en europe à l'époque
un clair ce geste
seul pouvoir que la france à l'époque
vous permet par françois hollande n'a
pas fait ce geste pas plus que emmanuel
macron de phrases ce geste me rappelle
quand même de la france laisser passer
les bateaux
de l'accord en expliquant que c'est
c'est ce que dans l'est des côtes
espagnoles et des plus proches des
bateaux de réfugiés que des côtes
françaises donc nous sommes absolument
pas un pays généreux watch je suis
admiratif de ce café d'angela merkel et
montre d'ailleurs au passage
effectivement que lorsque vous avez mes
dirigeants courageux qui prennent des
décisions courageuses l'epr suivant des
citoyens sur il céda lâcheté qui rend la
vie explique en grande partie la montée
des extrêmes est pas tout le courage
politique quand vous assumez une
décision les gens sont derrière donc été
même si elle a gagné sans doute sur le
plan économique s'achevait par je vais
pas rentrer là dessus a fait preuve
d'une nouvelle était d'une manne été
incroyable il nous aurait fait ça en
france c'est un président qu'elle une
courage de le faire je pense que ça
aurait été beaucoup plus accepter qu'on
imagine nous ne sommes pas en travaux à
ce qu'on dit une nation et gaullistes on
peut être généreux et une fois tous les
jours mais les citoyens initiatique
locales et de mépris pour appris à me
réfugier pour accueillir les migrants
voilà c'est nous on n'a pas encore gagné
alors il nous reste trois minutes on n'a
pas tout aborder bien entendu sur un
gala merkel je vous laisse une minute
trente franck dedieu qu'est ce que vous
avez envie d'ajouter mais je j'ai envie
de dire quelque chose sur l'après merkel
c'est à dire que moi je redoute et je
vois que émergent dans des pour un peu
de deuxième gauche de social-démocratie
en disant regardez la social démocratie
elle n'est pas morte
il va falloir compter sur les allemands
qui vont à nouveau
peut-être peut-être faire de la dépense
autrement dit eh bien ils vont un peu
nous ressemble et je me rappelle très
bien lorsque skissim à gabriel arrive la
droite française y regarder ils vont
faire des programmes de relance et c'est
donc ils vont desserrer le fameux ce que
dit jean est très vrai dire que tout
cela effectivement a volé en éclats donc
c'est peut-être pas comparaison n'est
pas raison mais à la tendance je moi je
personnellement east pas par mama menons
mon expérience de observateurs de ce qui
s'est passé avec le spd est bien jeune
et je n'ai pas véritablement confiance
dans leur capacité à changer de modèle à
se montrer beaucoup plus généreux et à
augmenter les salaires
profondément les salaires des classes
moyennes allemandes qui pourrait à
nouveau consommer et donc quelque part
faire aussi je dirais par rapport aux
partenaires européens commercial que
sommes nous et bien c'est aussi je
dirais dvd des capacités à vendre des
produits aux allemands qui pourrait à
nouveau consommer parce que c'est ça
finalement le fait d'avoir la
demande intérieure et en particulier des
classes moyennes allemandes a aussi fait
souffrir les sociétés françaises
exportatrices qui étaient plutôt des
partenaires naturels de l'allemagne et
ça je crois que finalement le spd
poursuivra là dedans il était contre les
nationalisations il était favorable à
une certaine austérité budgétaire
alors est ce que finalement le il y a
une forme de sens de l'histoire qui fait
qu'il ya un ballon c'est un balancier
que je dirais un balancier
interventionniste d'état protecteur
d'état providence
je crains que je crains que ce ne soit
pas le cas qu'est ce que vous avez envie
d'ajouter jean quatremer
nous consacrer à l'avenir je pense que
le principal enjeu de la future
coalition ça va transformer les
logiciels allemand en matière de
sécurité et de politique étrangère
l'allemagne s'est rêvé pendant très
longtemps en espèce de grosse suisse
commerçante commerçants avaient aussi
bien avec la russie qu'avec la chine est
à l'abri pouplier clair' américain tout
ça a volé en éclats ils n'ont pas vu
venir la nouvelle guerre froide entre
les états unis et la chine donc ça veut
dire une grande partie leurs
investissements et leurs commerces qui
font avec la chine va sans doute cesser
ou être obligée de se retourner vers
l'europe les tableaux d'un mouvement
pivot c'est dommage parce que c'est
pâques il nous n'aurions pas choisi mais
ça leur est imposée par les américains
de même aujourd'hui américain clairement
dit karl ont signifié aux européens que
la question de défense vieux continent
étaient plus leur affaire que c'était
aux européens d'assurer leur défense et
donc il va falloir que les allemands
sortent de leur espèce de pacifisme béat
compréhensive entre 1945 et je dirais la
chute de l'union soviétique
mais aujourd'hui qu'il est plus tôt et
donc ça veut dire construire une défense
européenne ça va être extrêmement
compliqué on commence à essayer d'en
faire de faire de l'industrie européenne
de défense avec l'avion combat le futur
le chat un combat le futur le drone et
cetera il va falloir a même beaucoup
plus loin pour assurer une autonomie
stratégique et là aussi on voit que les
par exemple logiciel de la cd ou a
commencé à lévis muet comme le promet
discours en pologne le président de la
commission européenne qu'il appelle une
autonomie stratégie de l'europe donc
c'est ça l'enjeu de la future coalition
expliquer aux allemands que le monde
pénale qui vivait le commerçant en paix
avec le monde s'était mis n'est qu'on
rend de nouveau dans le grand jeu le
grand jeu de puissance je vous remercie
tous les deux d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]